aquí tengo una pregunta si tenemos dos
cargas positivas sabemos que se van a
repeler entre sí si las quiero acercar
esta carga azul va a repeler a la carga
verde y viceversa pero cómo es que
sucede esto exactamente es decir no hay
nada entre estas dos cargas como es que
la carga azul esté empujando a la carga
verde sin siquiera tocarla es algo
bastante extraño si yo quiero empujar
algo que se encuentra en la habitación
donde estoy
necesito caminar hacia esta cosa y
tocarla físicamente para empujarla sin
embargo esta carga azul parece que
ejerce una fuerza sobre la carga verde
teniendo espacio vacío entre ellas aquí
no hay nada físico tangible que podamos
ver que haga que esto empuje a esta otra
carga y a los físicos les da vergüenza
no conocer la razón de esto es decir
podemos calcular con exactitud la fuerza
ejercida sobre cada carga pero no
sabemos cómo es que esto está
corriendo no tiene sentido el que una
carga empuje a otra a través de espacios
potencialmente vastos en el universo
esta podría ser una distancia enorme y
sin embargo de alguna forma esta carga
de aquí sabe a aquí hay otra carga que
me está empujando como es esto posible y
esto no es algo nuevo en las fuerzas
eléctricas este también fue un problema
cuando newton descubrió cómo calcular la
fuerza de gravedad dijo bueno podemos
conocer con cuánta fuerza la tierra va a
jalar a la luna y las personas dijeron
oye esto es genial ahora podemos
calcular y predecir las órbitas de los
planetas y cometas pero cuando las
personas dijeron oye newton esto está
muy bien pero como es que la tierra está
jalando a la luna cuando no hay nada
entre ellas newton dijo básicamente pues
no lo sé no sé cómo es que esto funciona
pero conozco las matemáticas para
calcular esto con exactitud así
desde la época de newton esto ha estado
en las mentes de los físicos desde hace
cientos de años hasta que llegamos a la
fuerza eléctrica las personas se han
venido preguntando cómo es que se
transmite esta fuerza a distancia existe
algo aquí que esté haciendo que la
tierra jale a la luna y por fin cuando
las personas comenzaron a tratar con
este fenómeno eléctrico decidieron que
ya era tiempo de responder cómo es que
los objetos ejercen fuerzas entre sí a
través de distancias potencialmente
vastas de espacio vacío y la persona que
encontró una explicación para esto se
llamó michael faraday aquí tenemos a
michael faraday él hizo su ciencia en
los años 1800 y se considera
generalmente como uno de los grandes
físicos y químicos de todo el tiempo y
lo que dijo faraday fue esto tenemos
esta carga positiva vamos a olvidarnos
de las otras cargas positivas y vamos a
concentrarnos en esta carga azul
positiva
esto es lo que está haciendo en realidad
esta carga positiva azul esta carga azul
está creando un campo eléctrico
alrededor de ella y abre veamos campo
eléctrico con la letra mayúscula y como
es un vector pondremos nuestra flecha de
vector arriba de ella así que parada y
dijo esta carga positiva está creando un
campo eléctrico alrededor de ella en
todo el espacio que la rodea y todo el
tiempo independientemente de que haya
otras cargas cercanas uno y el campo
eléctrico va a debilitarse cada vez más
conforme nos alejemos de la carga así
que cerca de la carga tendremos un campo
eléctrico grande y lejos de ella
tendremos un campo eléctrico pequeño
mientras más nos alejemos más débil será
el campo eléctrico así que podemos
imaginar esto como una telaraña que
rodea a la carga y la araña estaría en
el medio excepto que en lugar de la
araña tendríamos a la carga y la
telaraña es el campo eléctrico pero
tengan cuidado algunas personas ven esto
y piensan que está
la fuerza eléctrica pero esto no es una
fuerza estos vectores no son fuerzas
esto puede confundir mucho a las
personas padecen fuerzas porque estamos
acostumbrados a ver a las fuerzas
dibujadas como flechas pero aquí no son
fuerzas son vectores que también
representamos con flechas pero el campo
eléctrico no es lo mismo que la fuerza
eléctrica esto hay que tenerlo presente
no son lo mismo están muy relacionadas
pero no son lo mismo la fuerza eléctrica
es efe la representamos con una f
mayúscula y quizás una minúscula para
indicar que es fuerza eléctrica y ya que
es un vector le dibujamos el símbolo de
vector pero la fuerza eléctrica no es lo
mismo que el campo eléctrico que
denominamos y como es que se relacionan
de esta manera sabemos que el campo
eléctrico no es una fuerza puede ejercer
una fuerza eléctrica sobre otras cargas
lo que tenemos aquí es una carga
positiva solita que está creando su
propio campo eléctrico alrededor de ella
aquí no hay una fuerza eléctrica
necesitamos tener al menos dos cargas
para tener fuerza eléctrica esta carga
no va a ejercer ninguna fuerza por sí
sola por lo que esta carga azul que para
mantener las cosas claras vamos a llamar
a uno esta carga q no crea un campo
eléctrico en todo el espacio alrededor
de ella pero este campo eléctrico que
vamos a llamar en uno que está siendo
creado por q no está en uno no está
ejerciendo fuerza alguna en q uno va a
ejercer una fuerza sobre cualquier carga
que se encuentre en esta región así que
este campo eléctrico que es creado por q
no se queda y espera pacientemente como
lo haría una telaraña alrededor de una
araña esperando que se acerque alguna
otra carga por ahí y en ese momento va a
ejercer una fuerza sobre ella
hagamos otra carga por aquí digamos que
esta carga verde andaba moviéndose por
aquí y llegó a esta región no sabemos
por qué y en el momento en el que entra
en esta región tendrá una fuerza
eléctrica que será ejercida sobre ella
esta es la historia que nos dijo michael
faraday para tranquilizarlos y
explicarnos cómo es que trabaja esta
fuerza a distancia michael faraday dice
esto es lo que ocurre tenemos nuestra
carga con uno que crea un campo
eléctrico en todo el espacio que la
rodea incluyendo a este punto de aquí
donde pusimos esta carga que vamos a
llamar q2 ya había un campo eléctrico en
este punto que es creado por q1 y ahora
que llega a esta carga q2 por aquí q 2
va a revisar sus alrededores y verá que
en este punto de aquí existe un campo
eléctrico lo percibe y este campo
eléctrico que va hacia la derecha
una fuerza en q2 que va también hacia la
derecha causa una fuerza eléctrica el
campo eléctrico no es una fuerza
eléctrica pero va a provocar una fuerza
eléctrica sobre una carga que entra a
esta región y quizás se pregunten bueno
y esto en que mejora todo pues en que
mantiene las cosas locales a los físicos
les gusta cuando las cosas son locales y
por local queremos decir que para la
carga q2 cuando quieres saber que debe
hacer todo lo que tiene que conocer es
el espacio alrededor de ella misma se da
cuenta que en un campo eléctrico que la
rodea y que se encuentra en esta
dirección y sabe que va a sentir una
fuerza eléctrica que va a tener esta
misma dirección es decir esta carga
verde no tiene que saber que existe esta
carga azul q no que quizás se encuentra
al otro lado de la galaxia no tiene por
qué conocer qué es lo que está generando
este campo eléctrico o ejerciendo esta
fuerza sobre ella
se da cuenta de que hay un campo
eléctrico aquí y es todo lo que
necesitas saber para darse cuenta de la
fuerza eléctrica que va a ser ejercida
sobre ella y es así como faraday explicó
este fenómeno de cómo es que un objeto
está ejerciendo una fuerza sobre otro
objeto cuando no hay nada entre ellos lo
que él dice es que básicamente hay un
mediador esta primera carga crea un
campo eléctrico alrededor suyo que se
percibe en todas partes incluyendo en
este punto y este campo va a crear una
fuerza sobre esta carga cuando llega a
este punto así que esta es la forma en
la que conceptualmente explicamos esto
la carga q no está creando un campo
eléctrico en uno y el campo eléctrico es
uno en esta región va a ejercer una
fuerza sobre esta carga q2 y es así como
q 2 sabe que se está ejerciendo una
fuerza eléctrica sobre ella lo que
mantiene las cosas locales esta carga q
simplemente percibe el campo eléctrico
en el espacio que la rodea para saber
qué hacer no tiene que enterarse de qué
es lo que está causando ese campo
eléctrico pero en este punto ustedes me
pueden decir a ver un momento acaso q2
no está creando también su propio campo
eléctrico en todo el espacio alrededor
de q2 vamos a llamarle 2 ya que está
siendo creado por la carga 2 así que no
está creando su campo eléctrico
alrededor de ella como lo hacen todas
las cargas pues sí sí lo hace de hecho
va a crear un campo eléctrico por aquí
junto a kuno y es así como q no sabe que
debe sentir la fuerza que siente en la
dirección en la que la percibe y es así
como estas cargas se comunican entre sí
pueden imaginarse lo de esta forma las
cargas se comunican entre sí mediante el
campo eléctrico una carga crea su campo
eléctrico que está encima de la otra
carga y esta otra carga siente la fuerza
otra carga crea su campo eléctrico que
toca a la primera carga y esta primera
carga siente la fuerza correspondiente
así que conceptualmente es así como
funciona esto del campo eléctrico y
quizá aquí ustedes no estén muy
convencidos de que esto sea así quizás
piensen que eso lo estamos inventando
una historia para hacernos sentir mejor
para explicar cómo ocurre esto será esto
un cuento de hadas para explicar cómo
ocurre esto y así no nos sintamos
extraños de hablar de fuerzas que se
ejercen entre espacios vacíos y
distancias enormes hay algún beneficio
en todo esto y si si lo hay hay un
beneficio enorme matemáticamente en
términos de física a hablar sobre el
campo eléctrico hace que describir la
física sea mucho más sencillo y de hecho
tan es así que no tenemos que conocer
cuál es la carga que está creando este
campo eléctrico para nada si tenemos una
forma de conocer el campo eléctrico aún
si desconocemos cuál es la carga qué
está creando podremos encontrar la
fuerza que será ejercida sobre cualquier
carga que se encuentre en este campo
eléctrico sin tener que conocer cuál es
la carga que está creando este campo que
es algo que sucede con frecuencia así
que el campo eléctrico es extremadamente
útil nos permite determinar la fuerza
eléctrica ejercida sobre una carga aún
desconociendo la carga que está
ejerciendo esta fuerza y hasta este
punto he tratado de motivarlos o
explicarles por qué es importante que
los físicos llegarán a esta idea pero no
los culpar y así en este momento me
dijeran bueno sigo sin saber qué es el
campo eléctrico sé lo que no es no es
una fuerza el campo eléctrico no es
fuerza eléctrica pero qué es exactamente
el campo eléctrico así que permítanme
darles una definición apropiada del
campo eléctrico el campo eléctrico es en
un punto en el espacio se define como la
cantidad de fuerza eléctrica por carga
en ese punto en el espacio esta es la
definición del campo eléctrico es la
fuerza sobre la carga y los físicos
usualmente piensan en esto como
imaginamos que esta carga de prueba es
realmente pequeña de manera que no
afecta a la carga que está creando este
campo de otra manera si pusiéramos aquí
una carga grande todas las demás cargas
se dispersarían aquí y toda esta
situación cambiaría por completo así que
aquí ponemos una carga de prueba
realmente pequeña si yo quiero conocer
cuál es el campo eléctrico en un punto
en el espacio pongo aquí mi carga de
prueba miro la cantidad de fuerza
eléctrica ejercida sobre esta carga de
prueba y simplemente la dividido entre
la cantidad de carga que tiene nuestra
carga de prueba cuál fue la carga de
esta carga de prueba que llamaré q2 mido
la fuerza ejercida sobre q2 y la
dividido entre q 2 y este será el valor
del campo eléctrico en este punto en el
espacio y es
así como definimos el campo eléctrico la
definición de campo eléctrico es la
cantidad de fuerza por carga vamos a
poner valores aquí digamos que esta
carga q 2 es de 2 kilos aunque esto de
hecho es una cantidad de carga enorme es
un ejemplo poco realista pero nos
facilitará trabajar con los números y
conceptualmente es lo mismo tenemos dos
culos positivos que es el valor de q 2 y
vamos a medir la fuerza ejercida sobre q
2 que resulta es de 10 minutos en este
caso podremos decir que el campo
eléctrico en la vecindad de esta región
va a ser 10 newtons de fuerza entre dos
culos de carga lo que nos dará un campo
eléctrico de 5 y las unidades son
newtons colom lo que tiene sentido ya
que el campo eléctrico nos dice cuántos
newtons de fuerza obtendremos por culo
si ponemos más 'cool' oms en este punto
en el espacio tendremos una fuerza mayor
este número nos dice
la cantidad de newtons que vamos a
obtener por cada colombia y ya que
tenemos aquí dos colas y en este punto
en el espacio hay cinco newtons por
colom la fuerza es de 10 newtons así que
este número 5 newtons por colom es
importante porque es el mismo para
cualquier carga que pongamos aquí y es
por esto que el campo eléctrico nos es
útil este punto en el espacio de aquí si
tiene un campo eléctrico de 5 será de 5
newtons por colom sin importar qué
cantidad de carga pongamos aquí si yo
pusiera una carga de 4 kilos en este
punto ya que tengo un campo eléctrico de
5 newtons por culo tendremos una fuerza
de 20 newtons aquí ya que tenemos 5
newtons por cada color si hay cuatro
colores tendremos cuatro por 520 newtons
pueden imaginarse reacomodar esta
fórmula de otra manera multiplicamos
ambos lados por q y nos queda que la
fuerza eléctrica sobre una carga
es igual al valor de dicha carga en ese
punto en el espacio multiplicada por el
valor del campo eléctrico en ese mismo
punto en el espacio pero noten que este
campo eléctrico no está siendo creado
por esta carga que llamamos q2 esto fue
creado por otra carga o colección de
cargas recuerden que esta carga q no
está creando este campo eléctrico en uno
y este campo eléctrico es el que está
generando esta fuerza eléctrica en q2 q
2 no crea el campo eléctrico en uno que
es con el que está interactuando con uno
creó este campo eléctrico en uno y las
personas confunden mucho esto bien esta
fórmula y piensan que quizás q2 es quien
está creando este campo eléctrico pero
no es así este campo eléctrico está
generando la fuerza eléctrica sobre esta
carga no al revés esta q2 no está
creando este campo eléctrico es
este campo el que está ocasionando la
fuerza sobre esta carga así que esta
fórmula es bastante útil si conocen el
campo eléctrico en un punto en el
espacio pueden encontrar la fuerza
eléctrica de cualquier carga que se
ubique en este punto en el espacio
simplemente multiplicando entre sí ambos
valores y así obtienen la fuerza
eléctrica por lo que pueden darse cuenta
de que el campo eléctrico no es igual a
la fuerza eléctrica es la cantidad de
fuerza eléctrica por carga en un punto
en el espacio están muy relacionadas
pero son diferentes tan diferentes que
deben tener estas ideas separadas el
campo eléctrico no es la fuerza
eléctrica y viceversa la fuerza
eléctrica no es el campo eléctrico el
campo eléctrico es la cantidad de fuerza
eléctrica por carga y la fuerza
eléctrica sobre una carga en un punto en
el espacio es la cantidad de carga
multiplicada por el campo eléctrico en
ese punto en el espacio
y las cargas eléctricas crean campos
eléctricos estos campos eléctricos a su
vez crean fuerzas eléctricas sobre
aquellas cargas que se encuentren en
esta región
el valor del campo eléctrico representa
el número de newtons de fuerza por colom
en este punto en el espacio y en
términos de fórmula el campo eléctrico
es la cantidad de fuerza por carga o en
otras palabras la cantidad de fuerza
eléctrica es la carga multiplicada por
el campo eléctrico en este punto en el
espacio